bang
bang what's up guys lunch money time
while wall street's trying to get rich
the rest of us just trying to get our
lunch money right
i'm here with the intelligent and
beautiful paulina evilova marinova
pompliano p-i-m-p
what's up i don't know my hair is being
weird today i like the little
what the high pony is that they call
that oh you know a high phone
only because she says that all the time
don't forget
that lunch money is now sponsored by
block five block five has three
products they can allow you to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies you can deposit
crypto you can take out a us dollar loan
or my favorite product is you can earn
up to eight point six percent
apy in an interest interest-bearing
account
but before we get into the news
we got news about block fi go to
blockfi.com
lunch money can i share the news about
share the news
guys our friend right here the one
okay come on just tell the news
beautiful and intelligent anthony
pompliano
has invested in block fights latest
investment round
where they raised 50 million dollars in
series c
funding it was led by anthony and his
partners at morgan creek digital
alongside i didn't do it it was me jason
and mark i said you and your partners at
okay and an amazing list of co-investors
like
valor ventures overlar cmt digital
castle island ooh castle island ventures
i like that name
winklevoss capital scb10x avon ventures
purple archventures
kinetic capital hashkey michael antonov
oh is he bulgarian
nba player matthew della vidova and two
prestigious
university endowments did i do a good
job
block five race block fight raised the
50 million seriously
i'm joining the board of directors it's
legit
all right like does that make you legit
does that make me no it doesn't make me
legit it just means that i have to do
more work that's fine
zack flory and the rest of the block
fight team have done a fantastic job
zack has been on really go check out
blockfy
blockfy.com lunch money they
are doing an absolute crazy job they've
almost 10xed revenue
since the beginning of the year uh
they've got over 1.5 billion dollars in
assets under management
uh and things are uh are going well so
they're gonna take a shot at building a
much bigger business
zack the ceo and founder has been on
lunch money he has zach did a fantastic
job on
on lunch money he was dropping hot takes
all over the place dropping hot takes
like raindrops
oh you never heard that saying before go
ahead what's the next one
by the way blockfy.com lunch money go
check it out 50
million series c today why do you look
like a cat today
i don't know because i need a haircut
bad but come on what's going on what's
going on with apple
apple has become the first us company to
reach a
2 trillion market cap
apple you ain't got to be stunned all
over block fire like that damn
it's the first publicly traded u.s
company to reach a two tree i mean
publicly but also like privately right
i think it took apple what was it like
20 years something like that to reach a
trillion i forget how long it took
um and now it took two years to reach
the next trillion so the two trillion
dollar business that's
wild i remember when it hit a trillion
yeah i mean look
one it's a great business two they got a
ton of cash three
there's trillions of dollars being
pumped into the economy so of course
everything's inflated
um but can you believe that it passed
saudi aramco
well to become the world's most valuable
publicly traded company
yeah of course so if you had bought
apple in like 2018 even
you make a lot of so much money yeah
you'd be up like uh
three four hundred percent it's only
three or four x
yeah but like that's three or four x you
know i could go
buy more oh today i think starbucks has
a buy one get one
okay what's the next by the way uh apple
will probably continue to be very
dominant for a long period of time
except for
if epic uh ends up breaking their
monopoly on the 30
in the app store that'll be something to
pay attention to all right what's up
airbnb
files confidential ipo paperwork
i don't know why i'm being so traumatic
today bang bang let's go
so okay hold on a second so 2020 has not
been an easy year
for no no no we're we're having any
means we're gonna be biased today we're
only gonna present
positive airbnb news why
uh through an spv i'm an investor in
airbnb so we want this to go well we
don't want this to go poorly
when they go public we want the price to
go up because then we make it i have my
opinions okay share your unbiased admit
she's such a journalist
i'm just saying airbnb and may laid off
nearly 1900 employees are about 25
of the company the company also slashed
marketing costs and raised billions of
dollars in debt
numerous short-term rental hosts have
also complained about late or missing
payments from airbnb
i'm just saying get your [ __ ] together
in all seriousness even though
i want this to go well um this is really
crazy that the
i mean the pandemic really really
affected airbnb obviously people weren't
traveling
uh they also today just announced a ban
on global parties
so you can't have more than 16 people
come to us wait
that's our next topic stop ruining the
topic i can't see the topic so whatever
i'm just
i just read the internet i regurgitate
all the information with my analysis
on this fantastic show um and so they
had the layoffs
uh obviously revenue's down
significantly but what is more telling
to me is the fact that they're trying to
go public means that this is
such a positive uh frothy market
that everybody wants to get into the
public market cannot get it
like through my head that in a global
pandemic we're talk where numerous
people are laid off or furloughed or
don't have jobs
we're talking about how it's such a
frothy and great
market because the market is absurd to
me the market isn't a representation of
the economy it's a representation of
central bank actions
so what they basically did is they just
threw a bunch of money into the market
it's like you ever go to like the uh the
ball pit
at a mcdonald's you know in the
playground right if you go there
it's like a covet pit now yeah but if
you if you go
to like the playground and there's no
balls in the ball pit it's kind of
boring
right that's kind of what a like that's
a a liquidity crisis
is there's a bunch of kids playing and
there's only one ball in there and
everyone's fighting for that one ball
right so sharp elbows everyone's trying
to get the ball whatever
when a central bank steps in does
quantitative easing it's like they pull
up a dump truck and they just dump all
the balls in there
now every kid not only has one ball
every kid's got
so many balls they can't carry them all
right so the market is flushed with cash
it's all over the place and so what do
people do when the ball pit is full
they're like laying there they're
burying themselves in the ball pit
they're throwing the balls everywhere
they're having a blast that's what's
going on the markets right now
is literally there's so much cash
sloshing around
that every all the asset prices have
exploded there's people making tons of
money who are in the market
and people literally don't know what to
do with all the money
ball mcdonald's ball pits and central
banks only on lunch money
yeah that's that's a great explanation i
just came up with that off top of my
head
i know somewhere do you want to tell
people do you want to tell people what
you were reading last night
oh hand me my book if you don't if
you've never read this book this is a
fantastic book this
is a good one right here the dao of
capital it's from mark
spitznagel mark's i love that name
spitzningle mark spitznagel
uh used to be at the chicago board of
trade um and he basically learned
a very important lesson which is to take
small losses uh every single day
uh and wait for a very big catastrophic
event and so earlier this year
mark spitznagel's uh hedge fund was up
over four thousand percent
and what he basically does is he
basically buys out of the money
derivatives uh and he loses a little bit
of money every single day
uh and then when there's a big market
downturn he makes an absolute killing
but he only makes that killing you know
every five or ten years
um and so earlier this year he made four
thousand percent which is better
performance than most hedge funds over
the last decade
but he's lost money every single day up
until that point
um and so this book the dao of capital
is all about it's not about the
end result it's all about the process
but it's very good paul tudor jones
nasib taleb
uh steve forbes uh byron ween a bunch of
people
uh gave him quotes for it and stuff so
highly suggest
going to read it okay great okay next
are you done
um airbnb can just do a book review
go ahead airbnb has put a global ban
on all parties and events at its
listings for health reasons
but the home sharing platform made the
announcement in a blog post saying it
would also introduce a property
occupancy occupancy cap
of 16 people i'm sorry that's a lot of
people if you don't want a
random party to break out maybe cap it a
little lower
what kind of parties were you going to
sixteen people do you know what kind of
party i can throw with six sixteen
people is like the
pit 16 people like the pre-game for the
pre-game before the party
all right okay well where's the after
party after the after party
so you know what succeeds i'm trying to
go to bangers
with ball pits 300 people all right
so oh did we ever tell them about your
party at the
what was it called the uh lava no what
was it called
where the jay-z place oh the 40-40 club
the 40-40 club i one time accidentally
threw a christmas party
uh it was not accidental at the 40-40
club
uh kind of a lot of people showed up i
have never seen
so many boys men
whatever you want to call them coming up
to him and being like
no no no no no the whole idea was we we
had what
uh i don't think we had a thousand
people there but we had a lot it was a
lot of people seven eight hundred people
probably showed up to it i was very
confused there was a line out the door i
was very confused and pelina was shook
i was confused i was like it's christmas
time everyone wants to celebrate all
right what's going on with airbnb
you couldn't do that in an airplane so
the airbnb can you spin that no
okay the airbnb i like being off center
okay the camera keeps spinning
the airbnb um yesterday i was on airbnb
trying to find a home a house for
us and some friends to go away for a
weekend okay i typed in
six people looking for um houses with
six
people and it showed me a lovely cozy
one bedroom with one bed when i
specified i want six
people maybe they're brothers and
sisters and they all sleep in the same
bed
no i was like at this point in my life i
want
20 bedrooms that sleep three people not
three bedrooms that sleep
20 people anyway okay so moving on
ranting about your airbnb preferences
right now
i want all the balls in the mosque
what's going on with the
watch out for hidden fees on college
all right so colleges that are still
planning to bring students back to
campus
they have fees now they're adding new
fees on an already sky high tuition bill
so some of them are being more
transparent than others but merrimack
college in massachusetts for example
students that are
taking in-person classes must take a
covet 19 test
to help defray the cost each student is
required to pay
a covet 19 mitigation fee of 950
for the year so what if you're not going
to the school
if you can't go to college in person
it's not worth it yeah i agree
hot take totally agree because really
the only thing that college is good for
at this point for the most part for most
people
is uh one too
no i just saw former trump adviser steve
bannon was arrested
on charges of defrauding donors and
fundraising scheme
that's gonna be uh headline news for a
couple days um the
whole idea of college is either to one
build your personal network or two
to uh get the social experiences and so
if you don't get either one of those
like
you can learn everything that they teach
in the classroom on the internet yeah
and like for example university of
michigan will see their student fees
increase by nearly 500
in addition to a new 50 health and
safety charge
i just i understand but also
i don't understand yeah i'm not paying
well you're not going to college we all
know that i'm always in school though
one time i asked i was like do you think
it's worth it for me to get my mba or
something
and he was like no just go on youtube i
was like
all right let's not have that discussion
now yeah
i mean you could just go on youtube
where you could just start a business
but
or you could meet other really smart
people and i could find my engineer
there i could find my ceo there
do you know how to code unless you start
learning that's that's sheep mentality
you're a sheep you could build all kinds
of stuff you don't even need to
know how to code anymore there's the no
code didn't you trend didn't you just
say
in a previous lunch money that you
wanted to learn how to code this year
yeah i should
but i got other i got other things i'm
working on at the moment when is my
birthday
uh august 21st oh i mean 23rd no uh 26
no 24th thank you okay
tiger king zoo is closing and will
become
a film set dedicated to tv content it
was carol
[ __ ] baskin so jeff lowe who took
ownership of the park
after the film came out announced on
facebook that the old zoo will close
effective immediately because he was
forced to and the new park will at least
for the foreseeable future be a private
film set for tiger king
related television content for cable and
streaming
services smart he basically built a set
look this guy jeff lowe is backing into
some super lucky situations because that
guy was
up [ __ ] yeah he was uh hey can't be
calling people that
just be nice to people you just said it
was carol [ __ ] baskin
yeah it was i was mimicking somebody
it's fine i was true i think
this is how this is how debates in our
household go uh
i think that um jeff lowe was up shit's
creek and now all of a sudden this movie
comes out or
documentary whatever it goes viral now
he's like oh look at me i'm a film
producer
well the judge ruled that you have to
shut the freaking thing yeah i see it
but it went to carol baskin i told you
that's why
it got shut down because it literally
was carol baskin
just stating the facts all right what's
next well that that that's it
i know what's your joke oh yeah i was
looking up jokes oh shoot
hold on oh no okay do not look up funny
marriage jokes those are
not funny all right i don't what's next
i don't think
hold on give me a second um
[Music]
what do you call
hold on hold on hold on oh my god we've
done
all of these guys okay what do you call
the fear of being trapped in a chimney
fat kind of claustrophobia
what claustrophobia like oh like santa
claus yeah
see you these jokes are gonna be a
little intelligent no these jokes are
i literally said oh like santa claus
these jokes are so bad
but guys guess what august 24th is
planet's birthday i don't have any ideas
as to what to do i don't know to get her
for
a gift so you should leave a comment so
that you can help me and then it'll be
like
me and you guys give her something for
her birthday they're gonna say a bitcoin
don't say a bitcoin i don't know she's
not getting any bitcoin come on
you guys think i'm crazy so look at how
funny my hair all right guys that's it
for lunch monday today
while washing is trying to get rid of us
just trying to get our lunch money right
we will see you tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends